we have evolved through the ranks of our
ancestors outsmarting the Predators of
the world developing systems of material
and nutritional exchange creating health
practices and building incomprehensible
advanced technologies to facilitate
longevity safety and efficiency we have
reached the top of this world and yet a
great many of us see nothing from it as
our awareness has progressed alongside
everything else we have found ourselves
outgrowing more comfortable
short-sighted narratives of life and
moving into a realm in which there
appears to be no clear narrative or
reason at all but rather an absurdity
and meaninglessness underpinning
everything this is perhaps one of if not
the greatest contemporary issues of
humankind finding motivation and a sense
of meaning in a period of time in which
existence has revealed to be or at least
reveal to appear to be meaningless
arguably motivation to live and live
meaningfully cannot be founded on the
idea that life is a universally
meaningful or ultimately resolvable
thing if one finds that at its core it
isn't motivation rather must go beneath
the banal cliches of traditional ideals
of happiness success and grand meaning
and address the very real bleak nature
of our reality there is in fact no
one-size-fits-all prescription or cheat
sheet or instruction manual to life and
there is likely no ultimate circumstance
or idea or thing that will make life's
uncertainty pain and chaos go away
realizing and accepting this is likely
the first step only then can we consider
what might actually be real and enduring
in his novel breakfast of champions
American author Kurt Vonnegut writes
about an imaginary conversation between
two yeast cells
he writes they were discussing the
possible purposes of life as they ate
sugar and suffocated in their own
excrement because of their limited
intelligence they never came close to
guessing that they were making champagne
in this little allegory Vonnegut alludes
to the idea that with a limited
intelligence like our own comes
unlimited ability to see the larger
picture of which we are truly a part of
in this metaphor the yeast cells are
making champagne something relatively
insignificant but rather nice
nonetheless which is perhaps a pleasant
thought however by the same token it
could just as easily be something
not-so-nice the point is we are all in
essence merely passengers to this thing
and don't know what we are working
towards or why or if it is even any good
for us or about us we could all be
aggressively and competitively working
towards something worse than this or
indifferent to us or perhaps not the
only real honest conclusion is that we
don't know at first this idea of not
knowing what we're all doing might make
things feel absurd and meaningless and
that's fair however the following step
is to perhaps realize that this permits
us to no longer be subservient to some
specific grand meaning or template of
life that we don't have to nor should we
expect to discover or join in on someone
else's ultimate answer or way of living
nor attend to some future ideal or after
life but rather live based on what we
can do and no right now to attempt to
follow our own barometers of meaning and
believe in the only thing we have any
evidence to believe in at all our self
and its relationship with this little
sliver of time and space some of the
greatest minds in history have believed
and empirically found that we appear to
all have layers or processes of the self
that if circumstances are sufficient and
effort is directed towards it can lead
to a true or higher self a self
realization of personal purpose and
meaning this idea was proposed by
popular psychologist Abraham Maslow and
his pyramid of needs which is a five
tier pyramid diagram that illustrates
the order and balance of human needs
starting at material and physiological
needs like food water and safety and
then moving into psychological needs
like love and esteem and then finally
into what Maslow coined as self
actualization or living according to
one's true self and their full potential
somewhat similarly this was also alluded
to by renowned psychologist Carl Jung
with this concept of individuation which
suggests that there is a ring of outer
layers surrounding our true self
consisting of our outward artificial
social personas are unconscious hidden
layers being what Jung referred to as
our shadows and animus and anima and
then a core true self buried underneath
it all which when one goes through the
process of uncovering and realizing into
conscious expression a sense of
completeness harmony and vitality is
experi
these concepts along with others
unmentioned suggest that we each have a
sort of core self and source of meaning
and interest things we actually want and
should do with our life the things we
are motivated by therefore must not
merely be to impress others nor achieve
anything according to any societal
ideals for everyone has their own unique
complicated source of motivation that
leads to distinctive outputs of meaning
and feelings that feeling is worth
feeling at all
there are certainly shared common ideas
and methods of life worth considering
but one must attempt to take the input
of information and consider critically
how it might reflect on themselves
before assuming in the mass of
disillusioned individuals that are in
circumstances that could permit them to
perhaps be otherwise are likely not so
because life is meaningless but because
they willingly let themselves be pulled
from their own distracted and tempted by
the idea that somehow through enough
surplus money and stuff and achievement
of this and that according to other
people's ideas and constructions life
could be made completely happy and
perfect and certain however no matter
what one does no one can do this what
one can seem to do however is follow
discover and create a personal
meaningfulness out of the absurdity and
chaos that endures the fact that life
can never be such a thing the acceptance
and realization of one's self and the
creation of personal meaning is
unfathomably difficult to process and
understand let alone do it is perhaps
the true challenge of modern human
existence however it is perhaps the only
worthy possible one an arduous process
one must work and fight for into the
lights go out we are all incredibly
strange scared and some amount dissolute
even the kindest and most charismatic
person in the world at a close enough
distance and from a far enough distance
none of us matter at all and so however
cliche it may be we really are all in
this thing together whatever it is we
all need each other's words and music
and art and ideas and hands of effort
and eyes of honesty to help us through
it not because life is some perfect
happy
easy winnable thing not because anyone
knows what they're doing or what's going
on but because it isn't and because we
don't we are perhaps the only stop on
this evolutionary train that is outside
the tunnel of Darkness able to take the
material of everything and make it into
something beautiful or helpful or
interesting to understand and create
what meaning can even mean and to do so
just because we can because the universe
for some reason gave us a blank page to
write on thanks so much for watching if
you're interested in helping further
support pursuit of Wonder and have the
means you can do so over on the pursuit
of wonder patreon page any and all
contributions help sustain the channel
its quality of resources and ability to
grow and for that if you do choose to
become a supporter it is wholeheartedly
appreciated as a thank you any
contribution three dollars or more comes
with exclusive pursuit of wonder
offerings all video content will remain
free for all viewers here on YouTube so
not to worry if you do not or cannot you
can find the patreon page by clicking
the link in the description or the icon
on the left side of the screen
thanks again for watching in general and
see you next video